three boats intercepted in the space of
just 25 minutes yet another busy morning
for the border force on board
forty-three men and six women some of
them pictured here given face masks and
taken back to shore
and in tow one of the dinghies just a
couple of meters long clearly no chance
of social distancing scenes like those
along the Kent coast this morning have
become more and more frequent
there's been a massive increase in the
number of attempted channel crossings
since the start of the corona virus
outbreak since January at least 829
migrants have made it to the British
coast but on Monday alone ninety were
intercepted and the number arrested in
France planning to cross the channel has
risen by three times since this time
last year is concerning it does affect
the staff employed locally at the
borders is of a concern to the residents
and of course you know there's a danger
element to take extremely dangerous
walking blindfolded across the m25 so
there's dangers all the way around in
this but we are seen unprecedented
numbers and the reality is they're not
going to go down it's also led to
concerns about whether those coming
could be carrying the virus and could
spread it to others the government has
confirmed that those who are intercepted
won't be tested but will be monitored
for symptoms on the other side in Calais
coronavirus is having a dramatic impact
on the migrant camps the place they live
is very overcrowded and there's a lack
of sanitation so obviously the fear from
the virus is quite high but even more
than that the virus has meant that a lot
of NGOs have pulled out and the
government has cut back its services so
there are food and water shortages and
essential services like phone charging
and medical help have really disappeared
the government's say they are working
day and night to break up the gangs
bringing over the migrants the journey
has always been fraught with danger
now there's the added risk of
catching and spreading coronavirus to
sam holder Sky News